can we go b5  looks very tempting because you're not  only getting b5 in you're also getting  c4 and wow what just happened  c5 bishop takes e6 knight e6 and  magnus it looks like he  must have overlooked it magnus is having  a bit of a blunderfest right now  look at him he's really fed up with  himself  there you go oh my god the frustration  we are heading for a play-off  there we go you can see it so c5 wow  that was  tactics blunder strategically  too tempting as soon as magnus played it  i went  yeah of course we love that move yeah  why not of course we want to support the  night instant  mistake  after after so many games and and  against in this field  it's so easy to miss this stuff but very  frustrating for magnus it's exactly what  happened in their previous game magnus  just blundering upon to a check  a one move blunder the same thing again  and levon is back  into action here now